an attempted crackdown on hidden hotel
charges now face a potential roadblock
in Washington a growing number of
travelers complained that resort urban
or facility fees can add up to $50 to
your bill even lower price hotels are
adding the fees to room charges one
watchdog says the number of hotel
charging extra fees has grown 26 percent
year over year the size of the fee has
risen 12 percent our own watchdog and a
Warner is here with a struggle to
contain those charges and a good morning
good morning bianna well if you're a
typical traveler you probably go online
and compare hotel prices to get the best
deals especially for vacations or during
the holidays but what if that deal on a
hotel isn't one it was the most
expensive hotel room I'd ever paid for
in my life when Lauren Wolfe vacationed
in Key West last year she knew her $400
hotel room wasn't a bargain but when she
arrived at the front desk she learned
she'd also be required to pay a $20
resort fee it doesn't seem to make a lot
of sense it's not fair and it's just
taking advantage of people Wolf's an
attorney so after getting mad she got
busy starting a website called kill
resort fees to educate others and she
found she's not the only one who says
they were blindsided by fees this
customer says we got killed on
undisclosed resort fees didn't know
about them till we checked out another
very disappointed $25 a day urban
facility fee I was charged this with no
explanation of the benefits others
complain the services they're getting
for so-called resort fees don't add up
resort fee included - beach chairs there
was neither a beach nor pool another
guest wrote if you charge $29 for
complimentary recreation activities than
they aren't complimentary now District
of Columbia attorney general Karl Racine
is leading an investigation along with
attorneys general in 47 states into a
dozen major hotel chains what these
lodging companies do is they hook the
would-be buyer with a lower rate and
then spring the additional charge on
them we found this Las Vegas hotel
charging a room rate of
$26.00 with a resort fee of $34 this San
Francisco hotel adds a $20 urban
facility fee and this hotel in Arizona
listed its resort fee of $50 underneath
taxes what's illegal about it is that it
misleads consumers as to what the actual
price of a hotel room is even properties
with a certain famous name make money
off resort fees we found three Trump
hotels in Florida and Las Vegas charged
resort fees of $35 $20 and $24 for a
potential sixty six thousand dollars in
charges per day the American Hotel and
Lodging Association told us the hotel
industry provides guests full disclosure
for mandatory resort fees charged
upfront and says the hotels want to
provide consumers with the best value by
grouping amenity fees into one cost
following the FTC's guidance but in
January this year the FTC found charging
resort fees separately without first
disclosing the total hotel price likely
harms consumers and Racine says the FTC
was working with the states on their
investigation at least he says until the
Trump administration came in the FTC in
a way has gone dark and I think that to
be honest that has given some confidence
to the hospitality industry perhaps
they're going to be able to wade out or
otherwise evade the efforts of the 47
states because the FTC is no longer our
partner you're saying the FTC is backed
off that is the case backed off he
claims during a crucial time in
negotiations with the hotel chains and
we were heading towards what I thought
would be a pretty fair settlement really
yet the election hit and then all of a
sudden
the hospitality industry would have dug
in against our position we asked the FTC
about racing's allegations officials
there responded with a statement saying
the agency was never a co plaintiff with
the attorneys general but has worked
with the industry and state AG's to try
to improve disclosures about resort fees
we asked the Trump Organization and the
White House if they had any comments but
did not receive any response so the
lesson is we'll look at your bill or you
might call the hotel before you go if
you don't see any resort fees online you
might check directly with the hotel I
don't know mentoree not get it no and
there's five different charges on there
and that's what millions of Americans
are facing and it doesn't look like it's
changing right specially if you're a
family traveling for like for example
this week if you have two hotel rooms
because there's two of you in two older
kids and whites the resort fees right
now that $50 is $100 a night times six
that's 600 bucks a lot of money a lot of
money indeed and a Warner thank you as
always we appreciate it